foreign
[Music]
I've always been fascinated by human
systems because there's so many moving
single parts that somehow all come
together and form this system that just
works
what I find fascinating about the supply
chain is that it's a human-made system
as well and there's different moving
parts that are all independent but they
all have to come together to work as a
unit
my name is Andy Wang I'm a research
engineer at Institute and my focus is
applying AI to supply chain problems
from an early age I've always been
interested in making things more
efficient because you can see the
outcome in your own life and I've kind
of taken that into my career where now I
work in Deepak which is all about
efficiency
here at NCD we use machine learning to
help our customers improve their
efficiencies
similar to a human being the agent
learns by collecting more experience and
learning from this previous experience
these days everywhere you look you can
see that there's boxes and things need
to be shipped so the supply chain is a
hugely important part in our life and a
lot of the things that we take for
granted are because there's a system
working in the background
there is a butterfly effect when it
comes to making efficiency games if I am
able to take out a box in terms of space
from a container that might lead to a
container being taken off a ship and
eventually that will lead to a ship
being taken off the ocean and it has a
huge impact in our environment
now having worked on Deepak for a while
I noticed containers a lot more so
sometimes when I'm at the airport and
I'm sitting in a plane waiting to take
off I lock ice with a container and
cannot feel that it looks back at me
previously the container would ignore me
but these days it starts looking back at
me and there's this moment of
recognition
[Music]